y finalmente luego de ser pospuesta por
condiciones climáticas la primera misión
tripulada de la cápsula dragón de spacex
salió en ruta a la estación espacial
internacional
cuatro astronautas tres estadounidenses
y un japonés hacen parte de la misión
operacional de la aeronave la cápsula
fue diseñada y construida por space ex
compañía de cohetes fundada por el
empresario y lo más que cumpliendo el
horario la cápsula generó algarabía en
la nasa cuando el reloj marcaba las 7 y
veintisiete de la noche del domingo es
la primera vez que vamos a la estación
espacial internacional con una
tripulación de cuatro personas es la
primera vez que vamos con uno de
nuestros socios internacionales japón
así que hay muchas primeras veces en
este vuelo muchos descubrimientos serán
realizados por estos cuatro astronautas
en los próximos seis meses
el lanzamiento marca una nueva era para
la nasa luego de retirar sus
transbordadores espaciales en 2011
eeuu dependía de las aeronaves rusas
para transportar a sus astronautas a la
estación espacial internacional pero a
partir del domingo las misiones de la
unión americana saldrán desde suelo
propio washington espera que esta sea la
primera de muchas más misiones la
exitosa misión se dio luego de que se
hiciera un lanzamiento prueba a inicios
de este año de la que ya regresaron
los dos astronautas